how come you ain't never like me what  law is there say I got to like you no  all right then don't you eat every day  answer me when I talk to you don't you  eat every day yeah as long as you're in  my house you put a cell on the end of it  when you talk to me yes sir you eat  every day that's got a roof over your  head got clothes on your back yes sir  why you think that is because of you  hell I know it's because of me but why  do you think that is  because you like me  like you  I go out of here every morning I bust my  butt putting up with them crackers every  day cause I like you you're about the  biggest fool I ever saw as my job it's  my responsibility a man is supposed to  take care of his family you live in my  house for your belly with my food put  your behind on my bed because you're my  son  because I like you cause it's my duty to  take care of